What are some guidelines for circumventing chemo-induced neuropathy?
So chemo-induced neuropathy is when you're taking chemo and get its destruction.
So chemo-therapy is trying to kill cancer cells, but also it can kill other cells that are more susceptible to oxidative stress.
So remember, chemo-therapy is an oxidative stress therapy, so it's increasing oxidation.
Well, that's a bad thing, right? No, what cancer is in an already in a state of relative oxidative stress compared to healthy cells.
So when you add oxidative stress source like a poison like chemo-therapy, you will tip over a cancer cell before you kill a healthy cell.
Now you're going to kill some healthy cells, right?
And the healthy cells that you're more likely to kill is healthy cells that are more metabolically active, right?
Because they're uptake the chemo more, so what are those? You're hair follicles, right?
That's why people lose their hair when they do chemo-therapy.
More metabolically active, they're going to uptake more chemo-therapy, which is your immune system.
So your immune system, your bone marrow, is highly metabolically active.
It's going to uptake the chemo more, and it's going to damage you. That's the huge catch-22 with chemo-therapy, as you're going to have a damaged immune system.
So that's why they test your white blood cell canopy for administrative chemotherapy dose, because they can't let that get too low.
What else is highly metabolically active, your neurons? Your neurons are highly metabolically active, and your peripheral neuropathy is going to pool in the extracellular space, in the extracellular matrix.
That's the coolant of fluid and waste around cells. In your extremity, it's going to pool much more than in your core.
So you're going to have more damage to neurons in the extremity than you're going to have in the core.
That is what is chemo-therapy-induced neuropathy.
So you have a greater chance of damaging the neurons in your extremities.
So you're going to have loss of feeling at your fingertips, at your hands, at your toes, at your feet.
That's chemo-induced neuropathy.
So what are some things that you could do to help with that?
Well, vitamin B. Yes, vitamin B is a good, are good for your nerves.
That would be good.
Glutamine for neuropathy.
That would not be my first choice, especially glutamine if you're dealing with colon cancer, I wouldn't use glutamine.
Alpha-lopeic acid, that would probably help, but it would also negate the positive effects of the chemo-therapy.
Because alpha-lopeic acid is an antioxidant.
So if you're trying to take it and make sense, let's take an antioxidant.
So we decrease that oxidative stress of my neurons.
You have it. You're also decreasing the oxidative stress of your cancer.
You can't make the alpha-lopeic, can't make the antioxidant just go to your fingertips.
Yeah, that I wouldn't.
Vitamin B6 of all the bees would be probably the most applicable for the neuropathy.
Exercise, so this is what you get into different therapies.
So exercise, use of the nerves is the best.
Nerves, the way nerve pathways function is through they need oxygen and they need to be fired.
So if you want to keep a nerve pathway, you need to keep firing that nerve pathway.
Same thing with your brain.
You want to keep your brain alive, you got to keep learning new things.
You never stop learning, you never stop thinking, you never stop working your brain.
You're going to put your brain in pause mode because you're retired.
That's what you're going to start to see, you know, dementia, happening, et cetera.
Same thing with your peripheral nerves.
That's where that one tool that we have called the rebuilder.
The rebuilder is a tool that is approved that is FDA approved for peripheral neuropathy.
What it is, it stimulates at the frequency of the nerve.
So actually put your hands in a bucket of water.
It has to be a split bucket, not like your foot bath bucket.
And then you put one of the rubber pads in each side and you turn this thing on and you feel this tingle.
It's actually firing those peripheral nerves.
It really does work well.
We've used the rebuilder for well over 10 years, 15 years.
We used it a lot when we were doing brain-based therapy.
It's extremely beneficial.
You see a lot of peripheral neuropathy due to diabetes.
And it's extremely beneficial tool.
So think about getting a rebuilder.
But exercise, moving your hands, touching it, moving your feet,
having stimulation on your feet and your hands.
Vibration plates aren't fantastic to stimulate peripheral nerve.
So if you have, you can even buy an inexpensive foot massage vibration plate on Amazon for a couple hundred bucks.
Put your feet on that constantly.
You can put your hands on that.
Give you a lady, the nerve pathway, stimulating the sensory points in your hand and your feet is going to be key.
Because you've got to keep those nerves alive.
Because really what neuropathy is is damage to the nerves.
The nerves are dying.
So that can happen from diabetes.
So the most common cause of neuropathy is, you know, too elevated blood sugar.
And then chemotherapy.
So those things.
At one point after a chemo infusion to advise to return to coffee animals, I always say 48 hours.
So 48 hours after your chemo infusion and foot baths.
Pretty much, I would say 48 hours for that too.
Why do some medical folks say there's no evidence of coffee animals work?
Because there's no money in coffee animals.
I mean, they don't understand the neurology.
I mean, most medical folks are only spewing out the data that the drug companies gave them.
Unfortunately, there's very few people in the medical community that are self thinkers.
And the ones that are self thinkers have left the medical community and they've started their own practices.
And those are the people that you see doing TikTok videos that are trying to help people with a medical license.
So, you know, just go back to understanding, you know, the parasympathetic response, the whole purpose of coffee animals to stimulate your parasympathetic nerves.